hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute ich begrüße euch
hier aus dem urlaub in berlin wir sind
hier nämlich in einem coolen hotel das
hat unter anderem einen pool und da habe
ich mir gedacht wäre es nicht lustig
wenn wir eine unterwasser song challenge
machen also sind wir gerade eben in den
pool gegangen und haben unter wasser
irgendwie abwechslung jeder ein paar
lieder eingesungen das sind jan ja naja
ich bin krank crafter und es sind
insgesamt 16 videos die ich hier für
euch vorbereitet habe
da wollte ich jetzt eigentlich einfach
nur zeigen ich bin und dass ich unter
wasser filmen kann
[Musik]
was sagt ihr zu dem video aber ich würde
sagen dann kommen wir auch zum singen
wir machen das einfach feuer maßen ich
zeige euch im video wie ich singe und
geratet alle gleichzeitig darauf los was
es ist und der bds weiß schreibt einfach
los ich habe noch eine andere version
weil da hatte ich noch die kamera
gefilmt und festgestellt dass eigentlich
vor dem ist ja
dann hat man ja den ersten produktion
muss gehört ja ok als nächstes haben wir
hier escape klar was wir sowieso das
beste unter wasser sehen 32 richtigen
kurs deutlich machen nochmal 321 mal
anfangen wenn ihr es jetzt wisst dann
hört man es so sehr
wenn wir uns weiter ich finde ja dass
wenn man zwei meistens schon viele so
auf jeden fall oder so für viel verkehr
viele gesagt man wird piers erkannt
haben fand es echt gut natürlich mich
die auch mittragen natürlich und ich bin
glaube ich dass ich an den apple 321
energie aufgefallen ich wollte erst mal
eben angesagt von rolf ich möchte ganz
kurz darauf achten wir weiter mit
sebastian ich muss schon sagen leute ich
will nicht angeben aber mein unter
wasser gesetzt wir gucken uns das
nächste video hier haben das ist von
jana
aber diesmal richtig zu ende selbst
nicht was das ist was wir nicht erwarten
konnten
dann hast du schon mal okay nächstes
video von mir
[Musik]
groß heraus
als nächstes haben wir wieder ja also
ein loch graben ist es noch mal pause ja
auch kurz gedacht aber sie gehört haben
wir so richtig bis jetzt hatte laut
bistum keine luft mehr
okay das ist ein gesicht das dort
verlustig so aus du wirst du hast du der
bühne stehen und vortrag halten
das war glaube ich das mit abstand das
schlechteste was ist los
er hat auch die faktenlage
das macht alles über melody sie war
schauen auf die richtigen tun
wie sieht also dass man ja noch okay als
ich es bin ich dran
123 das haben wir doch einmal nahm ja
super können springt ja muss ich sagen
stimmt okay wir versuchen jetzt alle zu
erwarten alle auch du okay das war was
das war harry potter und der feuerkelch
doch das war das was dir etwas das eine
reine wasser machen
[Musik]
dazu gib mir dein herz spielen verrückt
dass ich silber führung mit teenage
gemacht habe aber ich habe ich habe
verschwiegen dass andere ansatz gewählt
ich habe schon wieder zumal man versteht
kein wort von dem was man sagt ja aber
das ist dagegen bei denen gesagt dass
man alle gegen die regeln die mir vorher
auch ausführlich mitgeteilt wurden hier
natürlich das ist erstmal keine nicht
suchen darf ok alles kann und das
allerletzte video für heute ist nur eins
von mir und der ist jetzt als erstes
erregt hat nicht von erfolg und scheiße
das spare nicht gewonnen das nicht
gewarnt ich würde sagen ich habe
waldmann alle von mir erwarten hat ich
habe nicht gesagt wer gewinnt wer errät
oder will gut gemacht ich habe gewonnen
gewonnen hat heute super da hab ich zu
meinem willkommen du kannst uns erklären
ist ein laser locker gewonnen hat heute
luca das war es eigentlich schon was zu
sagen okay dann bist du riester hier wir
sehen uns bis 1